foreign
moving on our main story tonight
concerns crime you know mcgruff's Kink
it's genuinely impressive that this
crime dog taught a whole generation how
to be narx while simultaneously dressing
like he's about to jerk it in the back
of a movie theater specifically we're
going to talk about how crime is covered
by the news because the news loves
covering crime sometimes seriously and
sometimes like this let's get this
straight from the start you're Nedra
Brantley right I am is your name Mike no
it's not this is what nidra's car looked
like today
Mike is a cheater who spray painted all
over it cheater cheater Mike is a
cheater Mike Mike Mike
see what you've done I don't know who
you are I don't know where you are but
you may want to start changing your ways
or changing your name yes
on my TV all day every day in fact if
you send NBC for Washington's Pat
Collins to Ukraine I guarantee you it'll
be sorted out tomorrow
see what you've done now you've
undoubtedly noticed that crime makes up
a significant part of your local news's
programming but the scale of that
coverage has a real impact research has
shown that viewing local TV news is
related to increased fear of and concern
about crime and the TV news viewers are
also more likely to support tougher
crime policies which does help explain
why our perceptions of crime can sharply
be at odds with the reality of it for
over 30 years Gallup has asked Americans
whether they think the US has more or
less crime compared to the year before
and in every year except for one the
public has said that crime was increased
even as the actual crime rate has
plummeted now interestingly the one year
that the majority said less was 2001
famously a year where everything was
super chill no drama just vibes
the news leans hard on this could happen
to you type of crime stories which are
designed to pull you in with the latest
version being this authorities continue
to sound the alarm about the dangers of
rainbow fentanyl another warning about
rainbow fentanyl the deadly drug
disguised as candy it is called rainbow
fentanyl the colorful candy-like
appearance is actually designed to
appeal to young kids they're attractive
they're colorful they look like candy
this is every parent's worst nightmare
especially in the month of October as
Halloween fast approaches this is
treacherous deception
to Market rainbow Fentanyl
like candy okay so first rainbow
fentanyl sounds like they're talking of
a very special episode of My Little Pony
but second while the idea of rainbow
fentanyl being made to Target kids
sounds very scary experts on narcotics
have pointed out that those pills are
almost certainly colored just to
differentiate products and it has
nothing to do with marketing to kids at
all period whatsoever which does make
sense does it because kids and this is
true are not an ideal customer base for
expensive street drugs because even if
dealers were targeting trick-or-treaters
were they first ones on the house
strategy where do you expect little Zeke
to come up with the cash for the next
one Sean's got his weekly allowance but
he smacked his brother yesterday so
that's that dollar gone and the rest of
his net worth is tied up in Lego Store
gift cards he is useless to dealers
maybe check back in 10 years when he
gets prescribed oxy after a lacrosse
injury and look that is not to say that
opioid addiction among young people
isn't a real issue it obviously is but
it doesn't help the conversation around
that issue tough newscasters jumping on
splashy your kids Halloween candy could
be fentanyl stories that even in this
report they half acknowledge his
[ __ ] right at the very end police
departments warning parents to check the
candy their kids bring home from
trick-or-treating we don't want to have
kids who are taking pills that they
think is candy and is really not
there have been no instances of that
happening yeah of course not
I'm so glad you taxed that disclaimer on
at the end there though I'm sure that
three second debunk red over the station
logo is exactly what everyone's going to
take away from that report and
definitely not the image of little hulks
sticking their hands into bowls of
skittle-shaped smack but that instinct
to run an eye-catching Crime Story
without being skeptical of its sourcing
is unfortunately incredibly common so
given that tonight let's talk about
crime reporting specifically the
incentives driving the outlets that
cover crime the flawed sources that they
rely upon and the greater harm that it
can do to all of us and let's start with
the obvious here crime has always driven
ratings The Mantra if it bleeds it leads
has been around for decades but the
philosophy really took hold around the
1970s when two local stations in
Philadelphia pioneered the eyewitness
and Action News format which leaned
heavily on crime news as one anchor
there explained crime was cheap to cover
it was easy to cover the assignment desk
said to the cameraman you shoot the
scene you shoot the blood you shoot
victims whatever they got and you can't
do it in 20 seconds but that is not good
the most meaningful stories are rarely
the fastest or the cheapest and I'm not
just saying that because I host very
long news stories that are also
expensive to produce the comedy show I'm
saying it because it's true nonetheless
those formats quickly spread to 200
markets around the country and by the
1990s CNN even did a whole piece
wondering if all that crime coverage was
necessarily a good thing
time news can look a lot like
entertainment the dark black
is crime coverage one Los Angeles
station a study showed spent over half
its newscasts on crime others came close
I'm convinced that if you could get
everyone who wanted to commit suicide to
do it on in a public place where the
media could be present we would have
like a TV show called suicide today
Wow way to bring down the room there
buddy but no not to step on that man's
creative Pursuits here there is already
Prime Time programming where people kill
themselves for our entertainment it's
called Monday Night Football happy
concussion season football fans it sure
feels like this sport maybe shouldn't
exist
people have been raising the alarm about
our obsession with crime news for a
while now but it's clearly been hard for
news outlets to give it up as they are
constantly making space for stories
about crimes be they major or incredibly
minor often Illustrated with mug shots
the new of Daily News even has mugshot
galleries on their website right now
with titles like criminally bad hair
days and babes Behind Bars and it's fun
isn't it it's fun because it's their
worst day
and the thing is the faces that get
shown can compound existing inequities
in our justice system a study a few
years ago here in New York found that
while around a quarter of the City's
population is black black people made up
for half of all arrests and three
quarters of criminals shown on the news
which is clearly going to distort public
perception and while Outlets May justify
reporting on Sensational arrest as part
of the public interest far too often
whether due to a lack of time or
resources or even inclination they don't
follow up on what the outcomes of those
cases are which can seriously impact
people's lives take DARS El Trotter he
and his brother were accused of sexual
assault in 2012 by a woman who not only
recanted her accusations but pled guilty
to filing a false police report the
problem is their charges had already
made the local news which then never got
around to mentioning that the charges
were dismissed and years later with
uncorrected stories still sitting on new
sites Darcel was having to make calls
like these how you doing Jim my name is
so we Trotter and it was an article
regarding of a accused of being accused
of sexual assault me my twin brothers
no you guys never did that
followers for drops yeah I mean that
would have been nice yeah it would have
been and if I could just talk to the gym
there for a second hi Jim I don't know
if that's uh short for James jimothy or
Jim Iroquois but either way Jim your
paper goofed you can't just report the
start of a story and ignore the end
imagine if the news hadn't covered the
end of balloon boy oh well guess he's
still up there the balloon has left my
immediate line of vision so who really
gives a [ __ ]
so the news media can be overly reliant
on eye-catching crime stories that are
quick and easy to turn around and the
speed with which the daily crime beat
operates actually leads to one of the
biggest issues in crime coverage which
is that it often relies heavily on a
single Source it is why if you watch the
TV news for any length of time you will
undoubtedly hear one particular phrase
the Lovington police say they know who
is responsible for a prank at a local
Park police and Fairfield say an officer
was attacked with bear spray policing no
suspects are in custody police say
police say police say police say
yeah please say it's a phrase that you
constantly hear from the mouths of news
reporters it's right up there with this
just in or back to you or I apologize
for the accent I did on Cinco de Mayo
and look there is obviously nothing
wrong with calling the police to ask
questions when you're working on a
deadline you can't always reach arrested
civilians or their attorneys who
sometimes don't even want to talk with
you anyway and please can be be easy to
reach many larger departments have even
set up robust media relations divisions
the LA County Sheriff's department has
42 people on its information Bureau at
an annual cost of 4.8 million and the
LAPD spends over 3 million for 25 people
in similar units which is already a
little telling because while a certain
amount of spending is necessary you
don't spend that much on PR if things
are going great
for context all those budgets combined
equal just one month's salary for Ezra
Miller's publicist they are so tired
they need to sleep
even smaller police departments can have
public information officers or pios and
as this one proudly knows his press
releases can make it straight to air
something major happens whether it's a
shooting or some major car accident
whatever it is you go back to your
office you type up this long press
release and you send it out to the
public and all the news agencies within
minutes you have reporters from all over
the country calling you there's
something strangely satisfying that when
you put out that press release hours
later you're watching the news and every
station that's talking about your story
is literally reading your press release
word for word okay set aside the fact
that everything about this man answers
the question what if Fred Durst but
worse that claimed that the police's
version of events can be parroted
verbatim in the Press is genuinely
alarming although I cannot really fault
him for being excited at seeing his work
red word for word on TV ask my writers
and they'll tell you they experience the
exact same thrill whenever I read one of
their little Jews jokes their parents
couldn't be prouder and by the way hey
Chrissy did you like hearing me say your
McGruff dog jerking it joke I bet you
did your college graduate
but the fact reporters will Echo pios
does explain certain things like the
ubiquity of phrases like officer
involved shooting you see it in police
accounts all the time but it's a weird
term for reporters to repeat because it
deliberately emits crucial information
about how the officer was involved if
you went to someone's house for dinner
and they said tonight there is a rat
involved dinner you justifiably have
some follow-up questions are we going to
a Chuck E cheese is the chef being
controlled by a tiny French rat under
his hats or are we going to be on an
episode of Kitchen Nightmares all three
are technically rat involved but some
options are easier to live with than
others
and honestly police departments don't
always need a Pio to push their
narrative as Outlets will sometimes just
grab [ __ ] from a law enforcement
agency's social media for instance
please love posting evidence from busts
that they've conducted like this one
which a Texas news station not only
shared on their own Facebook page but
even included on their evening broadcast
a search warrant executed Monday has
left three people behind bars the Tenaha
police department has released
information on the raid among the items
seized were two pounds of marijuana
illegally possessed prescription pills
drug paraphernalia packaging materials
guns and cash now if you don't really
think about what you are looking at
there I guess that seems like a story
right but is it because as many quickly
pointed out when you examine that photo
you realize not only is that not a lot
of drugs there is way less cash there
than they are going out of their way to
make it look most of those are singles
that is 70 total one commenter on the
Station's Post said sick this is play
school's my first dealer set with
another adding who was the drug dealer
El Cheapo and that that speaks to the
fact that there can be a gap sometimes
small but sometimes massive between the
story please are telling everyone and
the story that actually happened because
cop stories can for a lot of reasons
turn out to be very wrong in ways both
serious and Incredibly Petty take the
trend of cops claiming mistreatment at
the hands of fast food employees which
local news can be only too happy to
gobble right up there are possible hate
crime against police is being
investigated right now at a Shake Shack
in downtown Manhattan sources tell CBS 2
three officers became sick after having
shakes from the restaurant tonight
police suspect an employee may have
contaminated the drinks with bleach the
Leighton police Sergeant ordered a sub
and a lemonade from this Subway but
after taking a few sips of his drink he
quickly found out he got much more than
what he paid for he was having a hard
time maintaining his body his body was
jerking what caused those side effects
police say turned out to be a double
dose of illegal narcotics DJ a local law
enforcement officer told Eyewitness News
he suspects someone at McDonald's took a
bite from his sandwich before he
completed the sale tonight a McDonald's
in Junction City is investigating after
a police officer found insulting words
written on his coffee the f word has
been blurred out in this image of course
but you can see the word Pig written
right below it okay so there is a lot
there but real quick there was no bleach
in the shakes no drugs in the lemonade
the cup with the sandwich later admitted
he'd simply forgotten he took a bite
from it and the one with the coffee
admitted he'd written [ __ ] pig on his
own cup which is a serious Act of
self-loathing unless that is you are
Miss Piggy in which case it's a sleigh
out of the way boys she's got fashion to
work and frog dick to slurp whose copy
is that it's this [ __ ] pigs foreign
problems with deferring to police
because as many of you have undoubtedly
been yelling at your TV like I am a
wheel of fortune contestant who cannot
solve the puzzle please lie and they lie
a lot as you've seen on this show
they've lied to get search warrants to
conduct raids and to get confessions
during interrogations and they even lie
under oath so often in fact here in New
York it came to be known as tested lying
all of which should be more than enough
for the word of the police to be treated
with immense skepticism rather than
repeated verbatim take the notorious
press release the Minneapolis Police put
out following the murder of George Floyd
titled man dies after medical incident
during police interaction what you may
not know is it was picked up almost word
for word by local news the next morning
we do begin this morning with the
developing news a man is dead after what
police are calling a medical distress
after being handcuffed officers were
responding to a forgery in progress it
happened on the 3700 block of Chicago
Avenue South when they arrived officers
found a man they believed to be the
suspect sitting inside a car they
apparently told him to get out he
resisted officers eventually got him
handcuffed which is when he appeared to
have the medical issue the suspect was
taken to the hospital where he died a
short time later now obviously that is a
hugely self-serving statement from the
police because by saying George Floyd
died because of medical distress their
role was completely erased his medical
distress and I'm using the biggest air
quotes humanly possible here was the
result of an officer pressing his knee
into his neck for nine minutes repeating
that claim by the police is an act of
malpractice against a Walter Cronkite
saying JFK died of a headache today sure
it's not technically wrong but it's the
understatement of the [ __ ] century
the point is it was only after the
release of cell phone footage recorded
by a brave 17 year old girl that that
police narrative fell apart otherwise
that [ __ ] press release might well
have been the version of events that
everybody heard and that's not a one-off
an investigation last year of police
killings in California found at least a
dozen examples of initial police
statements misrepresenting events with
reports citing vague medical emergencies
without disclosing that officers had
caused the emergencies through their use
of force and in most instances media
Outlets repeated the police version of
events with little skepticism which
clearly isn't good there is a time and a
place for media Outlets to operate
without skepticism and we all know it's
the cover of Health magazines not an
ounce of critical thinking on this
extremely Real cover that includes the
headlines lose nine waist inches in 21
days and news a potato a day UPS weight
loss by 340 that is Rock Solid science
presumably
and there are times where the trust that
reporters place in some police sources
have been particularly egregious just
take what happened in Chicago after the
police shot teenager laquan McDonald 16
times in their initial coverage multiple
local Outlets featured interviews with
one particular person on the scene whose
version of events heavily favored the
police I don't know what his mental
state was but he wasn't dropping the
knife and he was coming at the officer
you obviously aren't going to sit down
and have a cup of coffee with them uh he
is a very serious threat to the officers
and he leaves them no choice at that
point but to defend themselves well
that's a very detailed picture painted
by Palm Beach Potato Head there but a
few things that you should know first
while he sounds like an eyewitness he
was not there for the incident second
videotape later revealed that that story
he was telling was complete horseshit
please shot McDonald's when he was
walking away from them but finally
reporters should have known to take
anything that guy said with a massive
grain of salt because Pat Camden was the
spokesperson for the Chicago Fraternal
Order of Police which functions as part
police Union part's special interest
Lobby group his only agenda was to
protect cops and it was way too easy for
this little mustachioed weirdo to hear
that there was a shooting drive to the
scene jump in front of cameras and grab
control of the narrative and camder did
this a lot one analysis found that in a
four-year time span he provided an
initial version of events for 35 police
shootings and in 15 cases crucial
aspects of his statements were later
proved to be false or misleading which
is just wild if you get caught cheating
at one Casino they ban you from every
casino this guy pedals brought it to the
Press 15 times and yet somehow his
picture wasn't pinned behind every news
desk in the country with the warning do
not ask this man about anything
so so so often it seems like news
outlets will be serving their
communities much better if they weren't
quite so trusting when it came to what
police tell them and to see a lot of
what I've talked about tonight in one
place just take what happened in
Brookside Alabama where a few years ago
local news was excitedly reporting on a
new initiative from their Police
Department which police said was getting
Real Results we tell you stories all the
time about crime going up but we got
some good news the town of Brookside
says they're seeing crime go down
Brookside is not a big town but it's
narcotics interdiction team they've been
busy another drug bust this weekend on
i-22 the Brookside police have been so
busy our number one goal is to not
prosecute people it's to save lives
that's why we got into this we want to
save lives we want to keep our citizens
safe we want to keep people who are
coming to Brookside safe and enjoy our
town all that coverage is just so weird
it's part local news fluff part
propaganda and something bordering on a
tourism ad from officer Teddy Rock's
been there but think about it it's a bit
strange that one Tiny Town in Alabama
had suddenly become a hotbed for drug
smuggling right well it turns out yes
and I will say to its Credit One local
station did dig a Little Deeper airing a
report about the fact that a weird
amount of drivers were questioning the
tickets written by that Police
Department a story incidentally that led
that department to tell employees that
anyone talking to that reporter would be
fired but it wasn't until two years
later that an in-depth investigation
from al.com revealed what had actually
been happening and that is that
Brookside a town of just 1200 people was
having its finances rocket fueled by
tickets and aggressive policing with
[ __ ] traffic tickets being issued at
a truly ridiculous rate
Brookside dragged so many people into
court that police had to direct traffic
on court days money from fines and
forfeitures soared more than 600 percent
to the point where it made up half the
town budget it's true it got to the
point where the police department was
taking in 487 dollars for every man
woman and child and spending it on among
other things a SWAT team a jail a fleet
of unmarked cars and two drug sniffing
dogs one of which they named and this is
true K-9 cash here is that dog and I
will say he does look like a canine
cache and that's not a compliment bad
dog
but the point is what was actually
happening in Brookside turned out to be
a pretty Far Cry from the initial
coverage of hey great news this small
town police force is apparently Miami
Vice all of a sudden anyway no further
questions
and the thing is by presenting police
uncritically you're not just helping
them Dodge accountability you're giving
them a huge lobbying platform right now
you don't have to look far to find cops
on TV suggesting that the fix for any
Rising crime is to undo the criminal
justice reforms of the past few years
and to give them more money and this can
get Real Results even the current
rainbow fentanyl scare started with a
DEA press release which happened to drop
just as Congress was in the midst of
budget negotiations everyone picked up
that story and what do you know last
week Chuck Schumer announced his
intention to allocate nearly 300 million
more dollars to law enforcement so that
they can fight the scourge of rainbow
Fentanyl and look I'm not saying all
crime reporting is bad there are some
incredible coverage out there we feature
it on this show all the time and a lot
of what I told you tonight came from
great investigative reporting but the
daily crime beat whether from lack of
resources lack of scrutiny or lack of
follow-through for far too often takes
place at their word and not as an
interest group who should be treated as
such so what should happen here well the
police could change the ways that they
both behave and communicate but given
that that's not going to be happening
anytime soon it unfortunately falls to
the rest of us for news outlets they
could try and snap out of their
automatic deference to police which is
actually possible just watch what
happened when a political web series
from the hill invited on a public
defender to discuss the case of Jalen
Walker who was killed by police after
fleeing a traffic stop watch her push
back when the host seems a little too
eager to accept the police line there's
no world no traffic infraction the
punishment is deaf not a one never so
there's no reason why eight officers
should choose to go and shoot him to
death I guess I just don't have a lot of
sympathy in this particular case
although I do it you don't have a lot of
sympathy in this case where he was shot
60 times after after leading the police
on a high-speed chase and returning fire
first of all let me just say this the
police no let's less because too often
media reports on what are police stories
as though it is the ultimate truth we
see too many too many discrepancies for
us to consent consistently lean on what
the police say is the truth that's what
we know I agree police say which has not
yet been substantiated or corroborated
they say they believe that one bullet
might have come from the window they say
that that's what they say their argument
is right who knows if that's exactly but
what I do know is that they shot this
boy 60 times for a traffic infraction I
know that yeah so
all right we'll have our Rising panel
join us next
tell us and to watch Baby Ryan Seacrest
trying to wrap up the segment after
getting his ass abs he handed to him
but while it's incredible to watch him
in real time backtrack from but I don't
have a lot of sympathy to oh absolutely
I agree who knows what is true it should
not be incumbent on that woman to walk
him to that point she can't be on every
local new set she has a life to live
and there are small changes that might
help reorient all of our thinking some
experts have suggested that rather than
going with police say Outlets should
consider going with police claim instead
which seems like a good start and to be
fair some Outlets are looking at other
changes some like the USA Today Network
have stopped publishing mugshot
galleries saying they feed into negative
stereotypes and are of limited news
value which they are and the Arizona
Republic has pledge that it will follow
any case that it covers to its
conclusion in courts or otherwise which
hopefully will save people like Darcel
Trotter from having to make phone calls
like the incredibly restrained one that
you saw him make earlier but the larger
cultural change might be for Outlets to
fundamentally reconsider whether the
crimes they're covering are actually
newsworthy because the truth is not all
crimes are and crime is only one small
slice of the much bigger picture that
they could be painting of what is
happening in communities the fact is
because crime news is pumped at US 24 7
the way it's reported it is deeply
linked with how it's both perceived by
the public and prosecuted by the state
and look we've said before local news is
incredibly important which is why it is
so critical that it is done well so to
the outlets who do put an undue amount
of weight on police statements and
prioritize Sensational crime coverage
over more complete pictures of Public
Safety if I may I would like to throw it
over to one of your own
see what you've done I don't know who
you are I don't know where you are but
you may want to start changing your ways
exactly